I became the most sophisticated
masturbator on the planet I did I jerked
off to Reubens Seurat Botticelli I
painted the balloon daily and semen
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen anybody funny bags
guys don't pockets you guys gotta check
out please give it up the recent picture
Hanson family and love and stuff like
that all those sweet ideas right there I
don't think I could have told this story
before like had he asked me to do this
in my 20s cuz the only person I loved
was myself back in my 20s I'm really
good I really did I actually the only
thing that made me cry in my 20s was
thinking myself dying um
I discovered that in acting class I was
serious I would think of myself dying
and I'd think about myself departing the
earth and think how sad it was for
everybody else and I'd cry and that's
twisted right but I grew up so now I'm
in my for do something and now that I'm
older I can talk to a little bit more
honestly about stuff like I have a table
but I was I've recently gone through
quite an experience with my mom and this
story is gonna deal with a lot with my
mom and she's an amazing woman she's the
coolest she's a cool say anything bad
about my mom I'll kill you I will love
my mom yeah raise me is she's an artist
and a nurse mainly an artist from a very
young age she is uh she exposed me to
art trying to get me to understand the
finer things in life and be really
sophisticated understanding sort of
value the beauty in the world and stuff
like that from like five or six she'd
have me up in her studio or in her room
and I'm just watching her paint and
stuff like that and first nudes I ever
saw first news I ever saw where my mom's
paintings which is kind of cool like and
not really good nudes I mean this is
rural Canada not a lot of great people
posed for art you didn't have the
sexiest people you've ever seen in my
Marla's art shows but they came in handy
when I started going through puberty and
I know isn't that gross and I'm not even
making that up the first thing I ever
masturbated to were sketches my mom's
made I know I know it's it's horrible
that lasted until I found her art books
and then all her art books were amazing
I became the most sophisticated
masturbator on the plan
I did I jerked off to Reuben Surratt
Botticelli Gustav Klimt I painted the
Louvre daily and semen I masturbate well
my mom saw was me walking up to my room
I thought with art books
loved art back then I did and a weird
thing happened we moved I was raised in
a very religious family and my dad lost
all of our money not through bad
business but because he became religious
he became a late Franciscan monk and
without telling my mom or anybody else
in the family and donated all our money
to charity and we went broke and we had
to move and so we moved and I quickly
put my stuff in boxes and I've got quite
a little porn by that point and I
remember writing on a box
do not look inside this is mine and I
put it in the truck assuming nobody
would look inside I was a naive child I
really was so I didn't think much about
it when we got to the new place the box
was missing about a month later before
school one morning about 6:00 a.m. mom
walks into the room door opens light
flips on what's going on mom drags a
chair behind her under her arm is that
box my gosh she sits down next to
me in the bed she goes pita little
concerned I know how much you love art
but I found these magazines and I had I
think the best thing to do is for me to
sit here and go through them with you
the very top magazine was a hustler I'll
never forget it was the first one I ever
bought and I had this blond-haired
Chinese girl on it I don't remember her
name but oh and my mom picks up the
magazine she flips it to the first
pictorial and there's a picture of this
naked girl and she goes well look at her
she's she's a beautiful woman there's
nothing wrong with that she takes good
care of herself and then she flips the
page over and like well that's a nice
photo that it's very artistically posed
she leans over the light catches her
very nicely that's all right and then
she flips the page over in the next page
is just two full pages of just a
close-up of her vagina just this massive
just staring out and my mom's just
oh just that delicate little oak just
crushed me right there she's like is
that how we should look at women is that
what women are just just a vagina just a
part just an object is that is that her
is that all we should look at the mass
just a utilized device for your own
gratification is that what a woman is is
it I don't know Mom I don't even look at
that page I skipped right over that way
she flips the page and she goes through
the entire magazine like this and I love
my mom but boy she knew how to up a
kids
and I thought it messed me up I really
did for the longest time I thought this
might have turned me into a into a into
a weirdo but it actually kind of made me
into a good person that's the kind of
the amazing thing about about my mom
she'd had a roundabout way of making me
better you know my mom got cancer quite
shortly after that it wasn't like it was
like it was a weird type of cancer I
don't know if anybody's experienced this
but it's kind of cancer where it doesn't
seem to kill her and she got diagnosed
with cancer and she had it for like 25
years 25 years of cancer that's the
Canadian medical system people fight for
it
but muhurta quick answer I didn't pay
attention to it I didn't focus on I just
took it for granted that she was sick
and then about four or five years ago I
was in I was in Switzerland doing gigs
and doing shows and I got a phone call
and lucerne i remember cuz my sisters
voice on the phone you know when you
pick up the phone there's all you know
there's something bad you know I heard
this crackling the voice and she goes
Pete you got to get home I go what's
wrong he goes well it's mom she's not
you got to get home I go well my gigs
finished in three days and I'll catch a
flight home she goes no no you got to
get home now and you can tell when you
hear that your voice like this isn't
this I don't got time to around I
gotta go now
and I've never done this before I grab
my stuff I told the promoter I was
leaving I got in a taxicab
and I had a little app on my phone for
plane tickets and I bought a plane
ticket on the app on the way to the
airport it cost me a fortune but I did
it because I needed to get home to see
my mom you know and I got to the airport
and the flight was leaving in about an
hour
I had two carry-on bag I'd go up to the
counter and I go hey I bought a ticket
on the way here here's the my passport
here's this I got to get on the flight
and late it's okay okay um do you have a
printout of the ticket and I go oh did
it on your app got no printout and the
taxi on the way here it goes well I
can't let you on the plane if you don't
have a printout of the ticket hey that's
crazy it's crazy I have an app you can't
print out anything could you print it
out for me cuz I can't print out you
need a printout or you can't get on the
plane well that's crazy and she
goes
and she goes if you swear I will have to
deny you boarding you won't be getting
on any planes today I'm like what mama
and I explained to her my mom's fat you
know she's really sick I got to get home
this is she goes you swore again
if you do this again you're gone and I
didn't know what to do and I was
panicking and I did the craziest thing
and I don't know if you've ever
encountered this sort of dehumanizing
bureaucracy when people try to put you
in a place and limit your expression
because they're just following rules and
not treating you like a human like a
little object but I just I grounded I I
just he came from my soul and people
started looking at the airport like
what's going on and I didn't know what
else to do because I couldn't swear but
I had all this manager walked over goes
what's going on here and I just and I
tears are coming down my face at this
point I go listen my mom's dying and I
got to get home and she won't let me get
on the plane and the guy goes don't
worry I'll get you on the plane I'll
take care of this and I growled my way
onto the plane I miraculously
got home in time I saw her she was still
lucid she was in a great deal of pain
but I got I got to talk to my mom before
you know before she passed but she was
in a lot of pain and my dad showed up
the joyous loving man that he is my
dad's incredibly religious in a crazy
way he believes all these crazy things
and one of the things he did while my
mom was suffering was he went to the
doctors and told them not to give her
painkillers I don't know if there's any
Catholics in here but there's something
called purgatory in Catholicism and the
things they do is that if you suffer a
lot of pain you can offer that pain up
to support souls in purgatory that'll
advance your admission into heaven crazy
idea but my mom was in pain and he was
withholding painkillers and I was like
no you can't do that and we got in this
huge fight but the doctor came in and
goes well he is her husband he gets to
decide what kind of pain management she
gets so we I can't give her painkillers
you guys see you know so I got my
brother to trick him outside and I went
to a nurse and this is I love
nurses and I explained it to her it's
like my mom is in a lot of pain she used
to be a nurse she goes I'll take care of
it
your dad's an asshole nurses oh I love
them but my mom that was the moment you
know and they gave her a little bit of
thing and she called me your little
fuzzy bear and she went into a coma and
that was it the last time I ever talked
to her she stayed in that coma for a
couple of days though she didn't come
out of it and I was like I couldn't I
wanted to stick around but I couldn't
because I have a family I have to
support I got to keep doing shows and
it's as much as it sucks I flew away and
I landed and I had to go onstage the
next night I got a phone call just
before going on stage that she passed
away he's like 30 minutes before going
on stage and I was just I was dying I
was dying but I went on stage I got in
front of people like you and I just got
up there and I and people acted like
what your well that's horrible that you
went on stage and told jokes the night
your mom died no it was an oasis
it was the best thing I ever experienced
because it was it was everything that
she put in me to become this to do
comedy to be in front of people
it invigorated me and I just and I loved
it I loved it now in quick epilogue
about two years ago I was uh back home
in my hometown and I got a phone call
from my sister again
she's always bringing good news and
[Music]
and she calls and she goes uh listen uh
it looks like dad's dying and I go ha ha
that's too bad
and and she goes well there's nobody
there with him he's all alone and I mean
you're only a couple hours away and it's
up to you nice I remember staying up
that night and just going hot and I
ended up waking up at 5 in the morning I
drove and I drove and went saw him in
the hospital
and there he was this bitter bitter
frail thin man lying in the bed none of
the none of the awful stuff he did
really didn't look like he was capable
of it anymore just lying there emaciated
just in the thing and I had all these
things I want to tell him you know all
this Howard's religion up my life
and all this stuff I wanted to say I
want to whisper in his ear and sell him
he didn't deserve the nothingness he was
about to encounter it's a up
thought is that for a religious person
but I didn't I didn't I saw him because
I was raised by my mom not him and I
just held his hand and I watched him and
the weirdest thing happened
nurse came in my dad was in a lot of
pain and asked what do you want what do
you want to want us to give him some
pain medication I was like oh gotta be
kidding me
no I want you to wake him up I want him
to feel every bit of this is
what I thought to myself but I didn't I
told him to give him the pain medication
because there's a weird lesson that in
my mom showing me that porn there was
there's this weird little lesson in my
mom showing me this porn where she told
me not to look at these little objects
to look at just a vagina and think that
was a woman it's just like him I can't
see him as just an asshole he's not he's
an entire person
and in that last moment I made the right
decision that we just leave and he
passed away without painting and that's
my happy little story
[Applause]
[Music]